you said recently that you find oh hello
you find
david beckham you guys are friends you
said that you find him attractive wanna
talk about that i merely meant sexually
[Laughter]
i think there's a point with beauty as
the greeks discovered in their wonderful
sculpture that it becomes irrelevant
what gender the person is if you have a
look at david beckham's abdomen i defy
you not to think momentarily of eating a
sunny-side up egg off of it
like a delicious egg that's what you
would do you would eat you'd find him so
attracted to a begging that you would
eat an egg off of his his abdomen that's
right conan yes and what if beckham
won't comply with this simple and
reasonable request right
or if you're watching your cholesterol
yes yes
then i say just tuck into some broccoli
by his nipple all right
all right gotta write that down now you
guys are friends have you told him that
you would like to eat a sensible
breakfast off of his abdomen
no actually i said it as a type of a
joke and then i saw him and i could see
in his face that he had heard about this
joke but i didn't have the confidence to
directly say it because when you're here
doing showing off you're in a different
mood than in real world where you might
require some bread or human contact yes
so you can't directly say david you know
i said that thing about that egg don't
let that disrupt the way you see me and
the planet you live on i won't actually
do it especially as at that moment i was
reaching my hands down his trousers okay
now that's just
ridiculous stupid thing to have said yes
i apologize the day after election day
the election you cared so much about not
that i'm saying that it's pointless or
anything i want everyone just to be
happy yeah that's a very nice wish for
people
just be happy yeah
you magical magical imp
russell you uh you have this television
show brand x and once i've seen our very
funny what new things do you have
planned for brand x oh this is ever so
good now we had a lady on there who in
spite of being a mexican lady herself
was against the idea of illegal
immigration and illegal aliens we had
her on the show to express her opinion
because america you can say what you
like can't you that's one of the
beautiful things about your wonderful
country so she came on to say that but
what i've done on the way is i went down
a shop what's called home depot it's a
big shop and outside there there were
some people that were illegal immigrants
so i got them and i got them in my car
and i took them to my tv program and
when she said there shouldn't be a legal
immigrant that goes roberto louise san
jose come out here and they all came out
santa jose he was a type of town
he was my favorite one
if i knew the way to him
very nice i'm right there with you and
then like uh they all came out and then
i dropped put masks on them so that they
wouldn't be arrested and deported and
that lady had to confront the human
consequences of bigotry that's a fact
but that sounds like a fascinating
segment it really does that's
that sounds like great television
yeah i just trying to do things that are
just disruptive unusual but
ultimately underscored by love which is
why i told david beckham about my
healthy tummy breakfast yes